David Cameron says he couldn't live on a
zero hours contract well nor could I
David but the difference with me is I'm
going to do something about it I'm gonna
legislate so if you do regular hours you
get a regular contract not a zero hours
contract and it goes to what kind of
country we build do we build a country
with security for working families and
for our young people based in thank you
you have it on the problem is it get bad
you know I look on the backs and turns
on that opportunity in ways they bought
it against a play from Riya mend meant
to end zero hour contracts in the KA
sector so why should people believe what
you say on zero well thank you all so we
I mean I think yeah makes a good point
because we discovered today there are
about 70 Labour MPs that employ people
on zero hours contracts and they
obviously haven't got a bit of at
practicing where they preach but there's
a bigger point here yesterday hundred of
business leaders from some of the most
iconic business brands large and small
said that the plan that we have is
getting the country back to work is
getting the country on the right track
and if we go off that with Ed Miliband's
plan we put the country at risk the
recovery at risk and jobs
there you have a young people have the
most important thing of their you have
it's a 0 in the corner emissary for our
economy to succeed what day you know
what you'll say their own jobs approach
that we got under labor - our by David
our defendant rifle lock me ups that is
a big choice there is a big choice of
this general election he thinks as long
as a few corporations and individuals do
well the richest the most powerful the
wealth will trickle down to everyone
else well he would try that experiment
over the last five years even fail
partly thank you very much indeed for
your comments on that very comprehensive